welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and one division's many mysteries
remain mysteries leaving folks like me
only with the scraps of my wanda vision
vision board that i tore down at 4am
friday morning i'm kidding i love this
ending i love this show but according to
the series director this finale episode
actually featured a deleted scene a kind
of alternate indian subplot
involving the rabbit senor scratchies
true demonic monstrous nature
no friends he was not a loose end he was
a very scary
real end that had a very real reason why
he was named scratchy
so let's dive into what was changed in
this finale episode and throughout this
whole season because there's a lot of
stuff that was tweaked that you can
actually see evidence for if you're
watching closely
so senor scratchy the rabbit pet of
agatha harkness was suspiciously built
up throughout the episode so much that
many of us believe that there had to
have been some deeper demonic secret to
him
like his name senior scratch he could be
a nod to the devil's nickname of old
scratch
aka mephisto or a nod to agatha's son
from the comics nicholas scratch
and that might have been who fiatro was
obviously our theories were all over the
place
rarely right and truly the friends we
made along the way but we did hold on to
the notion that this
rabbit wasn't just a rabbit he appeared
so prominently in that episode 2
animated intro and in key moments
throughout that episode along with
episode 7 with
billy mysteriously unable to read that
rabbit until the moment it was revealed
it was agatha all along
episode 8 dissolved from agatha's super
important origin flashback to a close-up
of this rabbit and then
later in that scene agave feeds this
rabbit a bird transmuted into an insect
still a bit weird since rabbits are
mostly known to be herbivores
right as this rabbit sits in front of an
open spell book as if guarding it but
alas episode 8 was the last we saw of
senior scratchy at least in the final
cut of these episodes becoming one of
many unresolved mysteries about this
series
until director matt shackman went on
kevin smith and mark bernardin's
batman beyond show and explained that
singer scratchy was actually
supposed to have a much bigger sequence
in the finale that would have affirmed
many of our observations
we did have something more uh planned
for senior scratchy which we ultimately
couldn't do just because
the finale we had so many different as i
said so many different chess pieces on
the
we did have a whole sequence where darcy
monica
ralph meet up with the kids and they're
in agatha's house and they
they think that maybe they should steal
the darkhold um from the basement
because the kids had seen it when they
were down there
being held hostage by agatha and they go
down there to get the book
and they're reaching for the book and
the rabbit hops up in front of the book
and they're like i don't say you're
scratchy he's the best and then like
reach over to pet him and he like hisses
and then this whole american werewolf in
london transformation happens and
the rabbit turns into this big demon
right into her like familiar you know
and uh and then gooney's set piece
ensues with all sorts of fun
as they try to escape from the rabbit
you know whoa
so confirmed folks this rabbit senior
scratchy is agatha's familiar
in supernatural lore in witchcraft a
familiar is kind of a companion entity
who assists the witch in carrying out
their dark magic
often it takes the form of an animal in
this case this familiar is a
secret demon transfigured into a rabbit
not at all harmless as i gathered from
his carnivorous appetite
and tasked with guarding the darkhold as
i noted by his placement on that altar
now american werewolf in london tells us
that shackman intended on a stomach
turning body horror transformation
and gooney set piece tells us that they
shot a kind of
stranger things-esque scramble between
these kids and
a hell beast
now timeline wise i assume this would
have been after monica pinned ralph and
took off the necklace
and around when billy and tommy went
outside to help actually perhaps billy's
sensing wanda's choke spell before she
actually did it in the following scene
could have been a result of this whole
re-editing
shackman said that he had to cut the
sequence because it would have been too
big of a detour from the main action of
the finale episode which he said they
finished editing just two weeks ago
after most of the season was already
locked in meaning he couldn't go back
and erase any of that setup he had done
for this rabbit sequence
so were we right about senior scratchy
being mephisto
not exactly but before we continue thank
you to bang energy for sponsoring this
video
every can of bang energy has zero
calories zero carbs zero
sugars and zero artificial flavors each
16-ounce can contains
300 milligrams of caffeine super
creatine coq10 and bcaas
i am sipping on rainbow unicorn not like
those thundercloud unicorns the unicorns
that make you feel happy when you sip
them
it's just sweet and light like you're on
the back of a unicorn
leaping over a more depressed unicorn i
honestly
rely on bangs when i'm shooting those
early morning after shows
and i don't want my eyes to look like
i'm half asleep when i'm trying to break
down these easter eggs i need my mind to
be alert
check out bang on instagram you can get
10 off your order at dangenergy.com when
you use the code new rockstars 10.
rainbow there you can buy a variety pack
of bang energy or grab a 12 pack of
citrus twist
bankster berry the new delish strawberry
kiss
use my code new rockstars 10 and receive
10
off your bang energy order that's code
new rockstars 10 for 10
off kevin smith actually brought up the
idea of the rabbit beam apisto to matt
shackman
you know what it's probably better that
the rabbit wasn't
like didn't turn into a monster because
then you'd have everybody going now
that's mepisto for you
that's great exactly yeah shackman's
laughing headshake there tells us that
while senior scratchy was
intended to be a badass shape-shifted
monstrous hell demon that is not the
badass shape-shifting monstrous hell
demon that mephisto is per se
that said various signs throughout this
series and in its post-credit scene do
still point to mephisto's possible
arrival
in future mcu titles i got more on that
in a video coming out soon either way
folks
dark magic demon monsters are confirmed
to be in the mcu now not just
nebulous beings like dormammu and other
dimensions but in this world
little scratchy hellspawn invoked by
satanic witchcraft
now i do not consider deleted scenes to
be firm canon
but that this was actually shot that
this was part of the overall creative
intention of the story
and that wandavision's success makes
shackman a golden boy whose ideas marvel
studios will adopt more and more going
forward tells us that marvel will be
going
in this demonic direction more in the
future shackman actually revealed much
of this series was reconfigured after it
was shot
they originally wanted to release the
first three episodes all at once and at
one point
ten episodes were planned things were
constantly changing and
getting re-broken story was changing
especially a lot of the real world stuff
and the finale
um there was a lot of of experimentation
going on and sort of trying different
things out
um we also at one point had 10 episodes
planned and we ended up collapsing a
couple
you know just to to to make the rhythm
feel a little bit better
this explains a lot of the questions you
might have had first that whole theory
that there was a secret tenth episode
nope but also some continuity issues in
the real world scenes that we saw
like norm's awakening moment with vision
showing up described on his file in
episode four
despite that not happening until episode
five and then kevin smith pointed
out a line that was inserted later after
principal photography when wanda told
monica in one of the final scenes
i don't understand this power
but i will yeah notice how elizabeth
olsen's face looks a bit different on
that line compared to her appearance in
the lines before and after
it's real subtle but wanda is framed a
bit closer
the lighting is weirdly even for an
outdoor shot her facial expressions
don't
exactly interact with her forehead and
neck as naturally as they do in the
other shots kevin smith called it and
matt shackman said he was right this was
a digital recomposition
the same thing they did with robert
downey jr saying i am iron man as he
snapped an avengers in game they shot
his face in close up later and swapped
it on his own body
marvel's vfx technology is freakishly
good
they are the devil in the details
support this channel by checking out one
of our great merch options at
newarkstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow me rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for everything marvel thanks
for watching
bunny demons
[Music]
you